quando l'organizzazione di milano mi ha
invitato mi sono subito chiesto se in
mezzo a tanti giovani di talento
scienziati attivisti creativi di ogni
genere e tipo come rappresentante della
dell'industria metalmeccanica non avrei
rischiato di fare la figura del del
dinosauro cattivo
devo dire che però la preparazione mi è
stata molto utile perché mi è permesso
in effetti di riflettere su un settore
da cui il lavoro in cui lavoro avremo
meno ormai più di vent'anni e che esiste
da più in realtà da più di 100 anni e
l'esercizio mi ha portato a concludere
che forse bisognerebbe pensare ancora
oggi pensare all'automobile come la più
tradizionale forma di new economy e che
forse chiamarsi o darsi del dinosauro
forse un pochino troppo prematuro forse
sarebbe meglio rinoceronte perché se
guardiamo i fatti
siamo ancora vivi e vegeti e forse un po
appesantiti e non tanto agili però siamo
in una discreta forma quindi proverò nei
prossimi quindici minuti con 16 minuti e
38 spiegarvi perché a mettere le cose
nel contesto è giusto perseguire un po
il tema della struttura del dell'evento
comincerei da ieri perché l'automobile
ha sempre avuto i suoi detrattori
già all'inizio del novecento molti
dubitavano che potesse sostituire ai
cavalli e carrozze se oggi
prima si parlava dell'impatto
sull'ambiente
ecco bisogna ricordarsi che in realtà
l'automobile era una killer application
no a quei tempi
riguardo all'impatto della mobilità
sull'ambiente quella che vedete è una
slide una foto del 1910 di londra e in
quel periodo
quella che non possono minare veniva
prodotta dai cosiddetti mezzi
tradizionali di trasporto in quantità
dell'ordine delle 1100 tonnellate al
giorno e parlo solo di quella solida
comunque ai tempi c'erano tanti
detrattori era c'era tanta gente che
pensava in realtà che l'auto ma non
avrebbe mai superato i cavalli o i treni
per esempio in termini di velocità e
questa la prima avente la prima sfida
della nostra industria
io credo che tutti hanno in mente le
grandi fotografie delle comprime
competizioni epiche o probabilmente vi
ricordate anche delle delle gare di
durata come una sola parigi pechino che
credo manco marco polo avrebbe voluto
fare con un solo cavalli per la verità è
che dopo semplicemente dieci anni le
automobili divennero più veloci dei
cavalli e dopo 20 più veloce dei treni
a quel punto tutti quanti sognano di
avere un'automobile però ovviamente
pochissimi se lo potevano permettere
quindi la sfida successiva della nostra
industria è stata quella di rendere
questo sogno la portata di tutti prima
negli stati uniti
poi in in europa di fatto il settore
dell'automobile ha letteralmente
stabilito il sistema di produzione di
massa
quello che oggi vi permette di
acquistare a prezzi relativamente
accessibile molti prodotti tra cui i
vostri laptop o i vostri i vostri jeans
tutti i moderni sistemi di produzione
dalla catena di montaggio ai robot per
esempio sono stati sperimentati e poi
stabiliti
grazie all'industria dell'automobile per
darvi un'idea visto che parliamo
parlavamo del l'inizio del secolo scorso
nel 1900 al 1910 al 1920
il prezzo al cliente di una vettura di
questo tipo la famosa ford t in dieci
anni venne praticamente diviso per tre
questo fenomeno
questa diciamo a questa evoluzione o
rivoluzione avvenuta più tardi in europa
in italia con automobili con la 600 la
500 e nel paese dove vivo oggi con con
il maggiolino che tutti conoscete
nella fase successiva l'industria
dell'automobile ha provocato un'altra
discontinuità che è ancora oggi un po
sulla bocca di tutti e che chiamiamo
open innovation l'obiettivo divenne
quello di rendere l'auto più comoda
della casa o quantomeno di farne un
estensione della della stessa
statistiche alla mano
statistiche alla mano vi dico che nei
favolosi anni 60 70 80 per cento degli
adulti aveva per così dire il suo primo
incontro di secondo tipo in auto forse
questo è anche un finché il motivo per
cui la patente si può ancora prendere il
solo 18 anni
comunque sta di fatto che sta di fatto
che molto di quello che c'era nelle case
è andato a finire nelle automobili dalle
poltrone in pelle alla radio all'aria
condizionata perfino perfino alla
televisione io sono convinto sono sicuro
dei pochissimi di voi a casa hanno
finestre che si aprono elettricamente
possono far scorrere il tetto poi si
apre un airbag nel momento in cui
nascono dalla scala quindi i tremila i
3.000 euro di una vettura media oggi
supera accessoriata prendono tutto
quanto il loro senso se sono confrontati
ai 6mila euro al metro quadro di un
monolocale in centro di milano manca
ammobiliato questo è quello che è
successo e quando vi parlo di open in
nome innovation parlo del fatto che oggi
il 70 per cento del valore del di
un'automobile è fatto
nella rete dei fornitori e ovviamente
una delle più grandi piattaforme di
collaborazione che esistono oggi sul
pianeta che dà lavoro a centinaia di
milioni di persone oggi quindi vi
vittima del suo successo con un mercato
mondiale che è sempre stato in costante
crescita
questa è la verità con centri urbani le
infrastrutture non sono mai riuscite a
stare al passo con questa domanda
crescente da ormai direi una quindicina
d'anni anche l'automobile si è
confrontata con il tema con la sfida
della sostenibilità è diventata una
priorità per noi come diceva françois io
vengo dal gruppo volkswagen
nei prossimi cinque anni
investiremo il due terzi degli 80
miliardi di euro che investiremo in
ricerca e sviluppo su tecnologie che
dovrebbero in qualche maniera limitare
l'impatto del dei nostri prodotti e
delle nostre attività sull'ambiente
ogni casa automobilistica lavora su
varie soluzioni dal downsizing dei
motori all'elettrico ai carburanti
alternativi ai materiali superleggeri
queste sono tutte tecnologie che
conoscete e che arriveranno vi dico
presto in grande serie
ma siccome siamo a ted e quindi credo
che siate più interessate a capire cosa
c'è
ma qualcosa lo posso dire dopo nella
dopo la prossima porta piuttosto che la
storia vi dico che io sono convinto che
la nostra prossima grande sfida sarà
quella di rendere l'automobile più
grande dell'automobile cerco di spiegare
un pochino meglio noi ci siamo
concentrati negli ultimi 100 anni su nel
riempire di contenuti tecnologici quei 6
8 10 metri quadri che produce di auto
che produciamo magari anche lavorando
insieme a fornitori industria
aerospaziale e dell'elettronica di
consumo del software o delle
telecomunicazioni al prossimo giro si
tratterà di connettere l'auto con
l'esterno
abbiamo ovviamente già dotato le nostre
auto di gancio di traino anche anche
elettrico come vedete grande successo in
olanda
sapete ma non è di questo di cui vi
parlo quello di cui vi parlo e che
vedono i nostri laboratori e quando
proviamo i prototipi si sta profilando
se volete l'opportunità di una nuova più
ampia delle finanze di definizione del
prodotto automobile è un prodotto che
non è limitato dal suo perimetro fisico
ma che è definito la sua integrazione in
un certo ecosistema ecco di fronte alla
possibilità di guardare all'automobile
con
diciamo oltre al mero oggetto fisico si
crea vi dico nella nostra industria
anche un cambio di prospettiva anche un
cambio di paradigma organizzativo in
aziende pesanti dove la l'idea di
specializzazione funzionale e di
competenza la fa da padrona e quindi
quando connettiamo il prodotto al suo
contesto si è costretti a passare da
un'idea di innovazione di prodotto a
un'idea di innovazione di sistema che
forse farebbe anche bene a qualcuno che
magari gestisce alcuni paesi è un po lo
stesso passaggio
se volete ci sono due buoni esempi che
rendono l'idea
basta guardare alle chart che utilizzava
uno dei più grandi imprenditori della
nostra epoca
nei suoi keynote per presentare per
esempio il suo rivoluzionario lettore di
file musicale nel 2001 e parlava di
andrà il super sottile parlava di durata
di batteria parlava di questo drive che
poteva contenere 1.000 canzoni e puoi
guardare alle chart che utilizzò nel
2007 presentando questa volta il suo
rivoluzionario o telefono che molti di
voi probabilmente hanno in tasca
mettendo questo prodotto al centro di un
mondo e mettendo questo prodotto al
centro di un sistema c'è un altro
esempio che forse ci azzecca come diceva
l'altro ancora un po di più con noi
perché viene da un settore della old
economy e anche della mobilità che è un
esempio che vengano delle scarpe da
tennis anche la più grande azienda del
settore sia a un certo punto resa conto
del limite della segmentazione del mix
dei concetti nell'estensione del della
gamma anche a loro i clienti chiedono
prezzo performance design qualità
eccetera
la loro intuizione fu quella di guardare
oltre alla soletta
ed è così che è nato il concetto di plus
che prima con esso il prodotto agli
smartphone che tanto non molliamo
nemmeno quando andiamo a correre e ii ha
creato una nuova moneta
i dati che i movimenti del vostro corpo
producono e che giustamente lo hanno
chiamato fuel il consumatore lo
scambiano con per informazioni che
possono essergli utili per vivere una
vita più sana
i venditori lo utilizzano per magari
trovare delle occasioni più di vendere e
l'azienda il marchio li utilizza
utilizza questi dati utilizza questo
fuel per rendere il suo marketing magari
più efficiente ed efficace quindi non è
una win win
ma in realtà è una win win win situation
è un fenomeno simile potrebbe anche
accadere da noi soprattutto se guardo
alle tecnologie che sono pronte all'uso
nei nostri laboratori e che permetterà
di connettere lato la rete
l'auto le infrastrutture l'auto agli
altri automobilisti e l'auto alle altre
auto sono particolarmente impressionato
da una serie di tecnologie che chiamerò
per convenzione le auto menti il
technology sono tutte quelle tecnologie
che considera consentiranno di estendere
o delegare le azioni del proprio corpo
all interazione col prodotto e sono
tutte pronte per la grande serie per
esempio la macchina trova da solo il
parcheggio vuoto a un isolato la
macchina va a parcheggiare da sola la
macchina vede oltre alla curva e
anticipa frenando se c'è una lastra di
ghiaccio perché la macchina che la
precede in quel punto ha perso tenuta la
macchina legge i segni stradali e
anticipa se semaforo sarà rosso o verde
ti fa prendere una traversa magari per
guadagnare qualche minuto
tutto ciò è basato essenzialmente su tre
tecnologie
la prima sono i sensori che mappano
quello che succede fuori e dentro l'auto
sanno se sei stanco
se le gomme sono sgonfio consumate e
quindi non hanno abbastanza green se la
distanza rispetto all'auto che ti
precede rispetto alla velocità e qui sta
viaggiando è troppo breve
oggi quasi tutte le nostre auto hanno
sensori fino a più di 100 senso
che ci permettono di gestire anche
l'interfaccia semplicemente con il
movimento degli occhi seconda tecnologia
sono gli angoli gli algoritmi algoritmi
intelligenti che riescono a gestire una
serie di dati per complessi nello spazio
di qualche millisecondo e terzo sono le
tecnologie telematiche che ovviamente
scambiano e condividono informazioni con
il contesto ecco l'opportunità è quella
di combinarle in un sistema per dare ai
nostri clienti
chiamiamoli così super poteri come in
kit car o in iron man kit car vale più
per la nostra generazione
questi poteri ti faranno ovviamente
arrivare prima e più sicuro bisogna
ricordarsi che il 90 per cento degli
incidenti viene dall errore umano però
come ogni storia di super eroe che si
rispetti i tuoi superpoteri potrebbero
anche andare a beneficio della comunità
e vi faccio un esempio tutti conoscete
il pilota automatico
insomma è quello che permette ai piloti
di jazz e di andare alla toilette e
durante i voli intercontinentali
esiste pure da noi ci abbiamo anche
vinto una gara leggendaria leggendaria
con questa macchina cosa che ha guidato
da sola per 27 minuti
mi direte che c'entra con il bene della
comunità
credo che sia abbastanza sempre il bene
più prezioso che abbiamo il tempo
no e de il tempo e la ricchezza che
viene da che cosa di questo tempo
noi facciamo riusciamo a fare
l'obiettivo è di contribuire anche
grazie a queste tecnologie ad offrire
alla gente la sua 25esima ora un'ora in
più per fare qualcosa di interessante o
di utile un ora e il tempo medio che è
un cinese un americano oggi spende nel
traffico urbano sono 72 miliardi di ore
in totale ho calcolato che se ognuno di
loro decidesse di indicare solo il 10
per cento del tempo guadagnato
in questa maniera sarebbe la più grande
organizzazione
non profit sul pianeta con i suoi 3
milioni di volontari che lavorano a
tempo pieno
ecco se pensate che tutto questo sia
futuristico vi dico che audi per esempio
potrebbe introdurre tutte le tecnologie
di cui vi ho parlato già entro la fine
di questo decennio
ovviamente una rivoluzione di sistema
che richiederà il contributo di altri
attori come chi fa le normative o chi
sviluppa e gestisce le infrastrutture
per la cosa è molto più che fattibile
lo posso dire anche con legittimità
perché siamo stati il primo è per adesso
unico costruttore ad ottenere una
licenza per poter operare un automobile
con il pilota automatico su strade
pubbliche per ora solo in nevada
questo è in realtà il primo motivo per
cui sono venuto qui oggi è quello di
provare a ispirare il desiderio a
qualcuno di voi magari fuori dal mio
settore magari architetti urbanisti
giuristi o semplicemente semplicemente
menti creative insomma ispirare il
desiderio di contribuire a creare queste
opportunità
il secondo motivo per cui ho deciso di
venire qui oggi è quello di provare a
convincervi che il meteorite che secondo
le previsioni di qualcuno dovrebbe
spazzarci via molto presto non è ancora
all'orizzonte è che se dovesse cadere
probabilmente troveremo ancora una volta
il modo di scansarsi quindi spero di
esserci riuscito e vi ringrazio
dell'attenzione